Is he in Paris?
I was.
Yeah.
It really looks like he's not.
He says he's away on his teens.
Okay.
OK, maybe he's in a Friday mood.
Thanks.
Probably mood, yeah, I think so.
The.
Okay, I don't know if...
How about Sophia? Do you do you see Sophia also away?
Well, it's just, um, I'll ask her.
Good.
Okay.
Yep, she said yes.
Hey, let's just wait for a moment.
OK.
This is.
Hello, Sofia.
Hi.
Hey, how are you?
Hey, Sophia, good afternoon.
I'm doing fine, thanks, and you?
I'm doing great. Thank you for asking. Just a few more hours to go and then we have a weekend ahead of us.
Yes, yes, yes.
Yeah.
I told you the best part of our meetings are that we are meeting on Fridays. So we always have a good mood.
Oh.
Yeah.
Yes.
Sometimes even the Fridays looks like Mondays.
Yes, it has been a week.
Yeah.
Ohh.
But for me, this Friday looks like Friday. So I'm happy.
Mhm.
Alright.
That's good.
Is Ray joining us?
Bill, Tammy mentioned he's away, so probably we guys can get started.
Mm.
He says he says he's yellow, he's yellow, so I don't think he's a...
Ohh, yep.
Oh, now he's red, so I'm not sure. I'll ask him.
Ohh.
Not sure, yes, so maybe just like proceed.
Yeah, sure. I think we can start if we join us and we can take it over from there. All right, well, thank you so much, Tammy and Sophia, for joining this call. So I'll quickly start with the feedback for Sally and Krishna both. I would first start with Sally. So
Yeah.
Sophia, if you could please let us know how she had been the past week.
Probably is.
For sure. Oh, yes.
Hello, Ray.
Harry.
Emil.
You're muted.
Everyone was missing you, Ray.
Yeah.
You will miss me a lot, by the way. I'm leaving. It's announced. Yeah, I'm leaving and Tammy will be taking over.
Oh.
So, yeah, yeah.
That's a shocking news for us.
It was my pleasure working with you, Sir, but really. Oh, you are one of the nicest. I met Ashish and we didn't work a lot was together, but yeah, but Sir Bajit, yeah, he was a very nice person.
Ohh.
Yep, uh...
Thank you.
Yeah.
Thank you, thank you so much.
I, I...
Yep.
So, yeah, Daniel will take over.
I.
But.
All right.
Ohh, yep.
But I'm still here till the end of the month, so I will be working with Tammy, with you and Sophia, of course, but yeah.
Ohh, good, good.
But they will take over shortly.
No, sure.
Not it, and wishing you all the very best, Ray, for your future interior, and hopefully our paths will grow.
No.
Thanks, my friend. Thanks for.
Yep, I wouldn't have expected this to come like this, because we were expecting you to join the call, and then all of a sudden you said that you were leaving, so we thought it truly came as a shocker.
Yeah, nope.
Yeah.
Yeah, who knows? Maybe we'll work together in a different company. Who knows? IT by design? Yeah, it seems you have a good name, but good. Yeah, maybe you have a good repetition. It seems that you have a good repetition.
Uh, yeah, that's that's that's also positive aspect of it, yes, I I get it.
So cool.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Post.
Yeah.
Yep.
Okay.
Because you're my because your name I heard in a different companies.
No.
Especially with technical guys, especially with engineers and technical IT.
Good to know.
Great.
Thank you so much, Ray.
No noise.
And sorry for being late, I just on a different call here.
No, it's completely fine.
Nobody expects perfectly OK.
So, uh, let's begin with Sally.
Sure, Sophia.
And.
Sally has been improving the task. It's more independent, but it's still working on that. I talked to her on...
Yep.
Yeah.
Wednesday, I believe, I just asked her to be more proactive, to not wait that I tell her, hey, we have tickets in the board, please work on the work on that. So she's going to be more proactive on the board, because now she's trying to,
She's doing the triage on the on the tickets, so she's solving the easy problems and assigned to Natalie, me, and the rest of the teams, whatever is more complicated.
Yep.
Right. So I guess what we want her to do is to be more proactive. And I guess in the previous Connect, Sophie mentioned that you want her to be independent in terms of finding things in Connect Price Manage and able to deal things on her own. So we did coach her and I think she's working on it.
Yes.
And it could take some more time for her to be good at it. And yeah, I think that's the plan is.
Yes, I advise her if she doesn't find information in 10 minutes, don't lose time. Just ask me and I can guide her. Because waiting or trying to fight for more than that is just a waste of time.
Yep.
Correct.
Okay.
Any other suggestions, feedbacks of you?
No, no, no. Overall, the work has been much better. Just these two things that she needs to keep working and be more proactive in the task, but that's it.
All right. Thank you so much, Sophia, for sharing the feedback. Tammy, please update us about Krishna.
Krishna.
Yes.
It's the same.
My personal opinion, like, is this the same? I mean, she does, so sorry, I know I'm getting mixed up. Sarah was on vacation on Monday and Tuesdays, and so Christian was backing her up. I don't know, because I don't see the emails. I don't know how she works on the POSOs. I see what they were fine.
Until Sarah, the next day says, "Oh, Krishna, you forgot to do this. You got to make sure you add a quote to the so that we know everything's attached." That's what I find out like afterwards. There are minor errors because she doesn't work on the pills every day like Sarah, so she's at the backup.
And I understand the mistakes, but I don't know, because I'm here two months and Krishna has been there longer. So I've just seen her for two months.
The PO, she, she's closing enough tickets in the PO, so she mentioned that she closed one day, 50 tickets. I think it was Wednesday and then, but on Mondays and Tuesdays, she was back up for,
Sarah, so she didn't cost as much tickets.
Yep.
When I went through Krishna's queue, and you're right, Tammy, she did provide backup for Sarah on April 13th and April 14th. Those were the days when she worked on sales order updates, invoice checks, and...
Yeah.
Yeah, sorry, yeah.
AP coordination. So yeah, this is what she did. However, I noticed that other than April 13th and 14th, she was able to clear match tickets from the vendor board. Yep, which was able to take her to a respectable total towards the end of the week.
Yes, sure, yes.
Any other suggestions or feedback, Tammy?
I always, no, ask her to just make sure any questions, always reach out. Just doesn't matter what it is, just contact me and I will help you out. So she's been doing that.
Z.
Okay, great. Any advice that you would want to give Krishna that she can work on?
So.
Um...
No, that was not just my main is that make sure that she any questions, always like ask. Just don't let it sit there. Any that's that's my point with her is ask, ask, ask.
Okay. Yep.
That's it.
I, I have a question: Ray, as we were talking yesterday, I know that it is still going to...
to be approved by Tyson. But if Sally takes the call, I think that maybe she should change the time that she's in starting, because she's starting with me at 7. But if she's going to take calls, should be at 830, 830 to 5.
Yeah, of course, it's fine with me. Just check with Ashish and Sir Bajit. If they're fine, if we can kill the time, that's fine, yeah. So from 8 to 5, yeah, if this is fine with you, Ashish and Sir Bajit, we can be, when do you want to begin, Sophia?
Yes.
525.
Sure.
Will it be 8?
This is something that is still, sorry, this is still something that Time has to approve, but it was stuck yesterday and we will know next week. Because the idea is that Sally will be the first point of communication with the clients. That means that
Just.
Okay.
If it's too complicated, she's going to send Natalie or me, or if it's easy, she can deal with it. So that is the idea in the board and in calls. The part of calls is still pending to approval. If it's approved, I will think that she will change, she will need to change the
Yeah.
time from 8 to 530 or 830 to 5. I don't know the timing for here.
Okay, just give us the go ahead, Sophia, when you have the approval from Tyson, give us go ahead and then we can do it. So no worry. I think Ashish is fine, but here.
Yes, yes, we should be fine. So please take the internal approval, Sophia, and just email us and we can take it from there. That will not be a problem.
Okay, thank you.
Yep, but we would need like 3 to four days, you know, to balance out everything. So, whenever you give approval, so please have like three to four days as a buffer so that we can arrange an operation for, yeah.
A district.
Yes.
Okay.
I appreciate it. Yes, sir, you had a question.
Thank you. Yep. Thanks, Ash. So Sophia, the only thing which I just wanted to confirm because it's 9 hour shift, so it will be either 8 to 5 or 7 to 4 or depending on whatever you are looking for or 9 to 6. And that includes one hour of dinner break, lunch break.
Ohh.
Okay, it will be, we start at 8 and we end at, sorry, 830 to 5. That is our timing.
Mmh.
Buckle.
Okay, 830 to 5. Perfect. So I believe 8 to 5 will be sufficient in that case. Probably I can go ahead and Ash can go ahead and take a lead on this one.
Yes.
I can I can check internally and so yeah, you just let us know if if it's a then we can have it done. So you prefer 8 or you prefer 830?
Perfect.
830.
830. Okay.
I can cover the calls before that, and that is fine.
OK, so we can we can have her work from 8:30 to 5:30 because it has to be complete 9 hours shift, so yeah, I think that that should be fine.
Okay.
And that will be Eastern, right?
Eastern.
Easter is here.
What's?
Yes, yes, you come.
No, central, 7 to 4 central right now.
Yep, Central.
Oh, sorry, Central, yes.
Okay.
Thank you.
Central, it's like...
Central East Toronto. I was thinking, where is that?
One hour.
Yeah.
Central, no, no, no, no. Central is different, so it's East. You want to make it Eastern, so it's like now it's like 1 forty-five, so this is we want if we have it from 8 or your time, because I know they have your time is 12 forty-five.
Yes, and yes.
Ohh, my time, so, yes.
Your time, so from 8 it will be 7, it will be 8.
Because my time now is 12, 1243.
If it's 8 your time, so it's like 7 hour time E.
Yes, because we, no, should be 8:30, 8:30 my time.
Check.
We got that, we'll take care of the conversion, don't worry, Ray.
Yes, yes, my turn.
Yeah.
Yes, yeah.
They are in, they are in Manitoba.
Yeah.
Yes.
I'm sorry, I lost the entire conversation. My internet dropped, so I don't know what happened.
Yeah.
Be.
That will be 830 Central Time match. That will be 930 Eastern.
No.
Yes, correct. You are right, Tesser. You are right.
Okay, I got it.
Yes.
830 to 530.
OK, so we would wait for the approval, Sophia. Once you, once you we received the confirmation from you, then we'll proceed it from there.
Yes.
Okay. Any other questions, suggestions, Tammy, Sophia, Ray, you have?
No.
They are fun.
And that's it.
All right, Ray, I guess we are meeting in at least upcoming call 24th and on 1st May. You are not going until then?
Next week.
Yeah.
I will leave 28. My last day would be 28.
Okay.
But I think we have another meeting next week.
Alright.
Yes, yes. Okay, yep. Okay, so we will meet next week, then we can have further conversation on that day. So thank you so much for your time, everyone, and we'll see you next week. Thank you.
Yep.
Yes.
Ohh.
Thank you everyone. Thank you. See you. Bye bye. Bye.
Thank you.
Thank you, team. Have a good day. Happy weekend.
Bye, bye.
You too, bye.